the first four Superman movies weren't
all great films by any means but they
had a certain sweetness about them that
reflected the character's optimism in
the comics all that changed when Zack
snd took the range for 2013's Man of
Steel although darker overtones were
probably to be expected in the post-
Dark Knight world it was still difficult
for many longtime fans to accept the
rampant casual destruction Superman
helped Unleashed during his battle with
Zod in the Final Act even harder to
accept was his decision to end the fight
by snapping zod's neck Snider has
defended his decision repeatedly but
that plot Point Remains the focus of in
tense debate for some fans it undermines
the entire concept of the character and
when they saw it go down in the theater
they had one unavoidable reaction